morning that the corona virus pandemic
is far from over researchers at the
University of Minnesota say the outbreak
could last as long as two years and will
not be controlled until two thirds of
the world population is immune
at the same time social distancing
restrictions are being loosened in more
states despite none showing a two-week
decline in coronavirus cases as laid out
in federal health guidelines the Food
and Drug Administration is
green-lighting emergency use of an
antiviral drug that was found a short in
the recovery time for patients the
nation's death toll from the corona
virus now tops 65,000 but on Friday the
last patient was discharged from the
field hospital at New York City's Maine
convention center that is where Michael
George begins our coverage this morning
Michael good morning Jeff good morning
this convention center converted to a
military field hospital has really been
a symbol for how hard the virus hit in
New York but as you mentioned yesterday
a sign of progress as the last patient
was released but doctors are now putting
out a warning across the nation saying
reopening too early could erase that
progress in California a fight over
access to the beaches in Maine the front
line is a brewery and it's time to get
Maine back open in state after state
protesters continue to defy orders to
stay home and keep businesses closed if
I walk in the sand and the police won't
arrest me harassment but you can be have
to go into the water and get me but a
University of Minnesota report released
Friday points out the dangers of that
attitude dr. Michael osterholm director
of the infectious disease research and
Policy Center spearheaded the study that
virus will keep transmitting as long as
it has to septal people that they can
get in now if we isolated everybody in
their own bubble Texas allowed retailers
and restaurants to open yesterday just
one day after the state reported a
record high single day death toll we
have a long ways to go in terms of the
number of people yet to be infected we
estimate that between 5 to 15 percent
the u.s. population has been in
affected and this virus will not slow
down its transmission until we get to 60
to 70% for governors basing policy on
scientific data and trying to hold the
line on reopening the message is simple
we're not out of the woods but we're not
out of the woods yet Maryland and
Virginia both reported their highest
one-day increase in cases Friday but
many who are eligible to return to work
may not go back in Pennsylvania a mock
funeral procession outside a Bell &
Evans meat plant underlined the point
that meat packers all over are putting
their health first there and at Tyson
Foods in Nebraska workers stayed home
until their concerns about health and
safety and often cramped conditions are
addressed in the broadest survey of the
problem to date the Centers for Disease
Control reported there have been almost
5,000 kovat 19 cases and 20 deaths at a
hundred and fifteen meat and poultry
processing plans in the 19 states that
reported data but triumph foods pork
plant in st. Joseph Missouri is
demonstrating what could be the new
normal
testing all workers before they can go
into the plans wanted to get ahead of
the wave instead of behind the wave when
92 workers tested positive they weren't
allowed in Clanton this size can stay in
operation still doing what they do to
keep the food supply chain open and yet
still test all their employees
simultaneously and here in New York the
epicenter of the outbreak the governor
is taking a more cautious approach
schools will be closed for the rest of
the academic school year some businesses
like construction and manufacturing
could reopen in about two weeks and as
the warm weather moves in this weekend
people are being told to continue social
distancing Michelle and high
transmission rates are what we're all
trying to avoid Michael thank you